[Music]
hello everyone Perry here for a brand
new comic-con exclusive I am sitting
here right now with the team behind
carnival row I watched a little of it so
first off I do have to say
congratulations because the scale and
scope of the show is through the roof
Travis I wanted to start with you we
were talking a little bit about it
before I love covering the blacklist and
the script was originally on the very
first blacklist so I am curious what was
going through your mind when you found
out it got on there and what was the
process like actually getting it made
right after that the process Wow
I wrote it in film school so I wrote it
a long time ago like 17 or 16 years ago
and it was like it wasn't really for
anyone but myself you know just for an
audience of one I never really thought
anything would come of it and and I'd
sort of sent it out to Hollywood cuz I
went to film school in North Carolina I
sent it out to Hollywood through an
alumni who had contacted me and said you
know in a real hushed tones like you
know I can't tell you much but you're
gonna start getting phone calls and and
really from that point on my life was
never the same and it just really like
it got a lot of attention immediately
and and I was not expecting it at all
cuz did you know what the black mist was
when I had no idea what the blacklist
was the first blackness yeah it was the
very first one yeah so it was like it
you know in in but it's it still felt
like an incredible honor you know I
think this sounds blacklist could be
good but it became became it was like it
became the thing I want to be for the
longest time I had to say like I don't
know or nothing because it was like it's
sort of despite the fact that everybody
really liked it sort of languished and
development hell for a variety of boring
reasons until you know very recently and
what was the thing that pulled it out of
development hell was it any individual
who jumped on or any single I don't know
it was a financing or something that
came together it was led
Darry because it was new line had bought
it as a feature and and didn't really
you know I'd set on it for a while until
they didn't really know what to do with
it and at some point legendary came in
and bought it from new line because I'd
worked with them before on Pacific Rim
and and they were really excited about
it and and it was Thomas Hall legendary
who called and said you know had you
ever have you ever considered doing this
as a TV show which immediately I thought
you know if I had written it like a like
a week later from when I ended up
writing it in Phillips I would have done
it as a team you try to begin with so it
just felt very you know natural to go
that in that direction and Mark when you
step in on something like this with all
of your experience do you read through a
script like this because it seems it
just seems so ambitious to me do you
just red flag so many things I could
because her concern actually you know
what was so great about the whole
production process was never once did we
say this can't be done
never once did we say there's not enough
money for this in fact Travis always
calls it like the irresponsible version
of the scripts
and that's basically what we you know
what we set up and it just the I think
the only compromise we made was like in
the first episode there's a rooftop
chase that that Orlando's character does
and originally was scripted to be in the
rain and the only reason it's not in the
rain is our stunt team said this is not
safe and we're like okay well then we
won't do it but we never said we can't
afford it I love the attitude that you
have with this you know nothing can't be
done do you think that comes with kind
of the changing landscape we're seeing
with like all the network shows but then
also the streaming services on the rise
oh absolutely I mean not even a question
and you know I was on the set with
Travis for one of the rooftop days and
there's like three techno cranes which
are these very expensive pieces of
equipment and if you're lucky in
broadcast television you can maybe get a
techno crane for like two out of nine
days there were three right there and
basically if you had just been draw air
dropped onto the set
you would have thought you were on a
movie set it didn't feel like a
television set the idea of stepping into
yet another fantasies scenario because
you have so much experience in that
realm is there no thing that can kind of
make you go like wow I can't believe I'm
seeing this on a TV show anymore or a
movie for that matter you know it was
when I first read this I was like wow I
don't think I've seen I haven't seen
this before it was to a point that was
made Travis made earlier you made reet
Ravis you know this this takes the idea
of this fantasy world and throws it like
years later so like if if Lord of the
Rings is like the original fantasy world
well we're like hundreds of years later
when you know the world of elves and men
are colliding in the most intricate and
unique and effed up and kind of way and
we get to sort of see these characters
through a lens where we can sort of
empathize and objectify and and be
objective about it because they're not
us you know what I mean we can sort of
see them and relate to them I think
that's one of the things that I love
about you know the way fantasy can play
into the world because it really excites
and ignites your imagination you know I
could not have said that better that's
exactly why I fall for the genre all the
time David with your character so I want
to describe this right because there are
so many little details of this I don't
want to misrepresent any of it so you
are a wealthy thawne who moves into an
affluent human neighborhood in defiance
of the social order so I got a little
taste of him in the first episode so
when you say defiance are we talking
about peaceful defiance or is there
maybe not necessarily violent but
something a little more brash to how
he's going about that that's really
interesting he's fooled defiance so
I think when you look at a grass you
have to it's helpful to understand what
it is to be in a community in a society
that set up one way and set up to allow
certain people to progress and what it
is to break through that whether that is
peaceful in whatever way you step
through that door or through or go
through that glass ceiling to yourself
may be peaceful just like actually I'm
not going I'm not going to accept the
limitations that society puts on me but
to other people that can seem quite
disruptive do you know what I mean and
so then you've got this constant
conversation in your head of like am I
being disruptive by just sitting here
and causing a fence to other people or
am I actually just living my life so
sometimes I think he's he comes across
as being like aggressive or brash or
whatever but I would find joy in just
even sometimes just just if in the scene
a Grace has to walk from his house to
the next door I'd find joy in looking at
the other humans that were around that
would sort of just look away and not
sometimes the supporting artists
wouldn't be expecting me to look at them
and say hi and then they would sort of
be like oh and I think that that's
that's him just living his life that
pitch makes me so eager to get more I
also want to get more of what's going on
here so this is just from how I read it
after one episode but I will be honest
your character comes across as maybe
like a little bit selfish in that
approach so yeah find any redeeming
qualities to her that we might see grow
a little more as the season progresses
well I I mean I think it's really
interesting when you play a character
who comes across basically in the first
episode as kind of a bit of a [ __ ]
like let's be honest kind of a bit of a
[ __ ] she
Spahn Rose is a very wealthy very
entitled young human woman and this guy
moves in next door and Imogen Imogen
spends most of her time at the window of
her drawing-room looking out basically
to see what's happening what she can
gossip about watching it be outraged
about and of course the perfect kind of
outrage outrage kind of incident happens
when he buys the biggest house not only
a house but the biggest house which is
adding insult to injury on the hole in
the hole of the Finisterre crossing so I
think with Imogen I absolutely love
playing this character who is quite hard
to take really I hope that people when
they see when they meet image and
they're like oh please like oh just just
shut up you know I really kind of I
invite that because I think that she is
quite an ignorant person when we first
meet her actually and she has a very
very long way to go and I think it's
really important to not try and make
your character too nice to likable like
I did not go there I did not try to make
image ad like oh she's fine you want to
find her like Abba noxus and kind of a
bit awful I wanna list eclis complex I
would say on this on the subject of
Imogen who's always been a very
difficult character to write for that
for that reason but but in seeing I
didn't realize who she was until I saw
Tamsin's audition frankly because it's
like and then I realized that it's like
oh this you know there's something she
brought to it that it was like she's
kind of weird
- maybe she's not just like she's not
just this like this superficial whatever
but under it there's this sort of weird
eccentricity that it's like she's not
this you know this is a costume she's
put on yeah that's actually that's
actually definitely part of the no it's
killing me right now I'm getting the rap
upside and there's so much I was gonna
say um so I think it's really important
yeah their image and actually what she's
what she really is as a frustrated
person she's she's frustrated with being
treated like a simple woman and actually
there's so much more to her and I think
I've kind of forgotten what I was really
gonna say that I think that because the
grace lives next door I think that's
what he finds really interesting about
her there's lots of humans going around
doing day-to-day things mundane things
but he is someone I think a Grace has
the ability to see underneath the veneer
and what's going on underneath that
veneer is of interest to him and I'll
leave you with that I am sold you guys
have to pave the way to a big ballroom
20 panel later today and also to the
premiere on Amazon August thirtieth guys
thank you so much for your huge
congratulations to everybody out there
please like and share this video
interview and keep an eye on the YouTube
channel cuz we're gonna more of them
coming your way real soon